here's what would happen if Earth was
one living organism the main theory
behind the one organism Earth is called
the Gaia Theory it argues that all
living organisms along with all of their
inorganic surroundings adapted and
evolved as a collective whole to form
one giant self-regulating system A
system that keeps its own checks and
balances in place in order for life to
survive on Earth the highly accredited
scientist James Lovelock believes that
since oxygen comes from plants and
methane as a result of bacteria Earth is
regulating its own atmosphere providing
the oxygen to support life and the
methane to help maintain a livable
temperature essentially the Earth is
basically keeping itself alive it's just
a theory for now but the Gaia Theory can
at least work as a reminder to people to
take better care of our planet because